en france quelle est la première force
politique en france les républicains
nous avons remporté toutes les élections
intermédiaires les valeurs que souhaite
que les français souhaitent voir défendu
il toutes ces valeurs là sont des
valeurs de droite
ce sont des valeurs portées et incarné
par les républicains et le centre en
france nous avons remporté toutes les
élections intermédiaires la république
en marche ou sélectif à quoi sa coque
non mais c'est le 2 % des républicains
va je vous parle des républicains nous
sommes la première force politique bien
ans
nous allons la majorité des
collectivités locales
regardez les régions de france elles
sont toutes à droite et d'ailleurs tous
les sondages par les sondages indiquent
que les présidents sortants seront
réélus ça ne vous suffit pas à léry
pécresse n'est plus républicain qu'ils
avaient brûlé le républicain c'est la
droite c'est la droite
oui non mais c'est la droite les
électeurs est ce que non mais ils sont
pas votées en marche
ils votent à droite ils n'ont pas voté
en marche la preuve c'est qu'en marche
n'est pas capable gérez votre internet
parce que parler d'un marché 1 quel est
votre adversaire principal c'est en
marche où c'est le rassemblement
nationaux moi je lui mettais à une
incidence est ce que vous les mettez à
égale distance
oui ou normes et pour terminer la droite
première force politique la droite
première en nombre de lits locaux
première en nombre de militants la
république en marche dernières élections
municipales à peine 2% et dans ces 2 %
pour l'essentiel ce sont des gens issus
une trahison les choeurs de trahison de
régner je compense de droite les
adversaires de république en marche mais
je vous pose une question égale distance
entre la république en marche et le
rassemblement national oui ou non la
république en marge se réduit à emmanuel
macron c'est un objet politique non
identifié le pire il estime je vous
réponds qu'il est le socle idéologique
dans marche et je vous dire si ce que je
combats quelle est la vision de la
république en marche et je vais vous
répondre
à chaque fois ils essayent de nous
braquer avec des pistolets en plastique
ou de grimper sur notre porte bagages à
chaque échéance
il tente ça je vous l'avais répond avec
le succès qu'on connaît regardez c'est
les rationnements gare échoué seulement
mais non plus demandé par la cij pour
répondre à la clarté
qu'est-ce qu'on veut égale distance
entre la burqa marché leur assemblée
nationale non moi je suivrai est ce que
c'est c'est de lutter contre
l'insécurité rétablir l'autorité mettra
fin à l'impunité réduire les inégalités
libérer l'économie je continue ou
j'arrête idéologique on va passer à
autre chose on va continuer parce que
moi je défends mes valeurs
et je veux que vous avez vu l'état de la
france moi je ne me résous pas à un état
aussi disloqué de la france est ce que
c'est normal qu'on tire à bout portant
sur un policier
est ce que c'est normal qu'on décapite à
l'enseignant est ce que c'est normal
qu'un gamin de 14 ans qu'une gamine de
15 ans alors je suis est normal alors
juste c'est contre ça que je veux lutter
alors jeu on est comme dans une
situation d'urgence d'urgence
sécuritaire et d'urgence judiciaire
aujourd'hui vous avez monsieur dupont
moretti veut présenter un projet de loi
de justice et sur la justice aujourd'hui
l'urgence et lyon urgent la confiance
voit le résultat
l'urgence et les ou politique pénale
vous avez entendu la politique pénale
vous avez eu plusieurs fois monsieur
dupont moretti sur le plateau mais
jamais vous lui avez dit quelle est
votre politique pénale
il manque une politique pénale
aujourd'hui faune politique pénale
claire et ferme c'est quoi une politique
pénale
c'est de dire on donne des instructions
des ferments interpellations des
ferments la justice réquisition de
prison ferme
réquisition de prison ferme requise et
demandé le mandat de dépôt à l'audience
rétablir et peines planchers les peines
plancher ont été fortement dissuasive
monsieur bourdin et là le gouvernement a
perdu du temps de ne pas vouloir les
rétablir et d'ailleurs les forces de
sécurité les réclames mais aussi mais
aussi construire des places de prison
si on transfère depuis 30 ans non pardon
non monsieur bourg d'argentan ce n'est
pas ce procès n'est pas construit en a
qui quand j'en ai pas construit mais
vous en avez construit là et sous ce
qu'elle se joignait n'a rien ce
quinquennat rien il va y en avoir quoi à
peine 1000 qui sont issus de dunes de
hollande sous nicolas semble non la b
2000 ap 2000 nous on en a fait plus de
9500 tous les grands plans de
construction de places de prison sont
issus des gouvernements de droite ça
c'est une réalité que vous vivez